a drug company named in a recent 60
minutes report for raising the price of
an easy-to-use opioid overdose overdose
drug is now slashing that price by more
than 95%
Kaleo is announcing today it will offer
naloxone injector called EV Zeo for one
hundred and seventy eight dollars for a
pack of two now that's down from its
previous price of forty one hundred
dollars in November
senators accused Kaleo of price gouging
Medicare saying the company not only
exploits a country in the middle of an
opioid crisis but also American
taxpayers
well Kaleo CEO denied those accusations
remember telling 60 minutes lesley stahl
that the company originally raised
prices to increase access to the product
i never understood that explanation
the fzo injector uses voice and visual
commands to help the user safely
administer naloxone and reverse the
effects of an overdose and there are
cheaper alternatives including the nasal
spray called narcan and the actual drug
naloxone can cost as little as a nickel
per dose the issue is courses people
don't have' them you know use of a
syringe and injected just in time